The story begins with Ishmael heading out to find a whaling ship to join.
On his way, he met a harpooning savage named Queequeg.
The two became quick friends.
They decided to sail on the ship Pequod.
The ship's captain, Ahab, wished to hunt for the white whale called Moby Dick.
The whale bit off Ahab's leg, so Ahab wanted revenge.
Many exciting stories were told of Moby Dick.
Many interesting stories of whaling and whales were also told.
The Pequod sailed over many seas, looking for Moby Dick.
They finally found Moby Dick.
Ahab was intent on killing the whale.
The hunt began, and it lasted for three days.
Eventually, the ship was sunk by the whale and the entire crew was killed,...
...except for one.
Only Ishmael survived, to be picked up by another vessel.
Only he was left to tell the tale.